[Music]
welcome back hopefully to uh another
segment of prepare like a pro I think
Julian did this one last week because we
had corporate chess league but I had a
great time doing it
the week before that
um so the big thing that's I'm hoping to
do today is to show you some of the
examples that I managed to kind of like
prepare ahead of time for against my
opponents and kind of um
you know show them the power of
preparation right so uh specifically in
some of the games I will show you today
I actually have a uh I have like five
games here I don't think we're gonna get
through all of them but if you get
through like two or three of them that
should already give you a good um
idea one of the games specifically I had
it prepared up until like last move it
was like 20 something moves in and I was
like I know my moves it was great so
um
the this kind of shows you that's like
when you're playing chess you're not
just playing the game you're also
playing the opponent so you need to kind
of use all of your
um fight power and your resources and
you kind of need to be sure that you are
um you you kind of can't get into your
opponent's head and figure out what they
want to do so even before the game
exhibit a let me show you this game that
I played against a very very strong I
think at the time he was International
Master but then later he became a
Grandmaster so swapnil
um we actually played again uh I think
two years after this maybe three years
after this actually and the game ended
in a drawer which again good good result
for me
but this specific game he played um it
was we were playing in um
Dubai open 2014 Jesus nine years ago
um but this was a really good game in
the sense that I was the wfm I was
hunting on my Wim Norms so it was like a
big deal for me to try to get as many
points from higher up as I could right
so he played the dragon and I kind of
expected him to play Dragon because I
did prepare before the game and
I um I was hoping that he would play
this line I have actually never ever
played this F4 line in my life before
this game but the night before the game
and the morning of the game I had enough
time to prepare and kind of learn the F4
line my reasoning was that I found a
couple games that he had played that he
played it quite poorly like he played
wonderful against like all these other
lines but against this like F4 he
actually played uh a little poorly and
so that gave me more hope to actually
play this F4 line because if you play
again if you play a game and you play it
bad and you played again and you played
that yeah you may actually like go learn
it fair but when somebody would play
against you you would again be like oh
my God this line again yes
find the games of your opponent so this
may be harder to do for you because of
the tournaments that you play but the
more tournaments you play especially the
more International tournaments that you
play there are going to be databases
from your opponent's games especially
when the games will be online nowadays
when I know who I'm playing I try to
find their chess.com or leeches
sorry I can't and take a quick look at
the games that they played like recently
so that helps a lot
yes
that's that is usually the case but for
whatever reason when I was playing in
Pan-American tournaments in January I
did find a lot of my opponent's username
but just like looking it up on Lee
chesterchess.com because I think for
chest.com they have to have their like
actual name somewhere in the database
not necessarily the username but
you may not always get lucky but I
especially when you're playing somebody
who has a rating especially like
International Master they're going to
have hundreds of games out there because
they have had to play like international
events to get stats rating and to get
that title so their games would be out
there
um in your case it might be harder to
make that because you play a younger age
group and you play less experienced
people but if you play like tournaments
that are more online you can also try to
like find their online games but it does
come in handy to try to like look up
your opponent's name even if you don't
think they're gonna have a game maybe
they'll have one or two games that might
help you so I do highly recommend always
checking out who you're playing don't
just go show up and just play especially
if it's like a serious tournament if
it's friendly sure
but I've always liked to be prepared so
um F4 and my appointment Knight C6 as I
expected
um so Knight takes Knight is the like
the more played line but I went for
Knight F3 because that was kind of what
I prepared
and like Bishop G7 is the most commonly
played one and if I remember correctly I
was hoping to just get the bishop out to
either C4 or D3 or short castle and just
play it comfortably uh he however played
Bishop G4 which kind of messed around a
little with my long Castle ideas because
it just kind of kind of like doesn't
work as well anymore
so I went ahead and I played H3 I'm kind
of like tickling my opponent to take it
because if he goes back I'm gonna have
G4S right so either you have to go back
back or you have to take so in this case
he took I took and then he developed the
bishop now question for the audience
um a line on in person
based off of how the position is which
side do you think you would want to
Castle
the right side
you can't Castle to see it you got to
get the Bishops out that's fair but you
if you wanted to go long Castle I think
you do need to be cautious about this
diagonal and this semi-open file
you should play Black pawns or like
ready and that Rook is like waiting
for you I think you can make a case for
both sides I think both sides are
actually fine it's more of a preference
um I prefer to go short side because I
don't know what where I want to put this
bishop maybe I want to go Bishop E3
maybe I want to go like Bishop somewhere
else in the future I just don't know
what I want to do with this bishop but
with this guy I know I want to play
Bishop D3 protect this buddy and uh
Bishop C4 may have also been desirable
but I mean queen B6 I may have to deal
with some issues here Bishop D3 kind of
like felt very natural for me even if
you do queen B6 again now I can try to
maybe like first of all
second of all
um oops second of all I don't really
want to but if I need to I can also do
queen F2 you may ask how is that
different from this you could again do
the same ideas uh but now there's Queen
B4 and I generally don't like to have
loose pieces
so
yep so level Bishop D3 and castle castle
and again my idea with trying to go long
Castle could have been fine too I don't
think there's absolutely anything wrong
with long Castle
um because there may be some
um discomfort with this but you do have
a pond storm happening as well
so I wanted to go short Castle partially
because that was also my preparation
haha and
now that my opponent is like opening up
this diagonal I started to think about
um
whether or not it's when would it be the
right time to maybe put try to push some
of these guys so what do you think is
there the right time to try to push F or
e or should we just develop or what do
we think
I think I would prefer development I
mean the ponds can always wait like if
you have all of your pieces developed
first then you can like bring the attack
and once and it'll be so powerful you
are correct you do need to be careful
about F5 ideas because you always give
up the E5 Square yeah especially as the
ceiling is very important to be mindful
of that so if I had the opportunity to
play E5 and like my I would just not
lose a pawn I would do it but I can't do
that just yet so Bishop E3 was my choice
this is a good diagonal for the bishop
uh I kind of possibly kind of question
I'm kind of questioning are you gonna go
Knight E5 C5 or what
um so my opponents went like before and
um it was a pretty strong idea I think
they could have still considered to
maybe get the queen out so maybe get the
Rook out but night before is also strong
the only thing is I I'm not really
worried about this tape because if you
take I'll take with the pawn and I'm
bringing another Pawn to the center and
I may even push this Pawn so I am
totally fine with you taking that so I
don't really know why my opponent played
night before I just developed
possibly and I I can see how this bishop
might become annoying in the future but
right now this is just like a harmless
little dude why do you need to take it
because if you take it I'm gonna take
with pop that's kind of the point
yeah
um so he went ahead and just develops
respectful uh and now again do we have
any of these guys
because you you did kind of develop more
thoroughly at the moment
so what now
well E5 take you may want to go F5
because then you take away the E5 Square
from upon its Knight
so just kind of sit let's I want people
to kind of like take a minute or two I'm
not a two minute my minutes maybe I'll
take through what might be good tier
between F5 and E5
so yes Bishop takes C3 would present a
possible issue because you would lose a
pawn so it is important to at least
acknowledge that and kind of go from
there
sorry
that is true
you could go for A5 but I don't think F5
right away
E5 would be a slightly better choice I
have to agree and E5 if take then F5 it
would be really nice right of course
they're not gonna take it because
that'll be just too good to be true
um
but they could just try to maybe get the
queen out somehow I I don't really I'm
not really going to take this at this
point I mean I could but it doesn't
really help my cause because they would
they could just take with the H right
and I add a pawn down
that is also correct so in the real game
I didn't play it because I thought I
thought the E5 is good but I mean I was
buying somebody 300 points higher than
me and I just chose to play something a
little bit more comfortable and I just
played F5 after F5 my opponents went
ahead and I think I think this might
have also been a good choice for them
and then when I moved the queen then
maybe the he could have tried to maybe
like take and then D5 he could have
tried to cause some trouble in the
center because now they want to play D4
so I have to address this I don't have
time for an attack
but
um my opponents didn't really play this
I think 95 personally would have been
kind of like more annoying for me or but
he just took it
which relieves a lot of pressure because
now if it's my move the E5 score is no
longer a problem because if you go 95
it's totally fine I'm just going to move
the coin somewhere later on I'm going to
play D4 and this is just great for me
um but after take the opponents didn't
really like I don't think he spent a
whole lot of time but he just took this
Knight and I take and I'm like well my
Bishop is not gonna be hopefully a
mountain monster
so I had a lot of fun with that
um something in the chat why would you
give black the E5 Square in this kind of
position so that's the thing like
F5 technically was okay it doesn't
really hurt your position it's like
you're getting something and you're
giving something up too so I think it's
really important to just kind of
um be very mindful of
like it's a trade-off you're getting
something you're giving up something
you're not just like giving up a whole
Square for nothing you are getting your
opponent F5 you may have some like
contact spawn you do have you do open up
your Bishop so it's not all bad if that
makes sense
so F5 wasn't bad but if we could make E5
first work that would have been even
better
right
cool now though I'm pretty happy I think
my opponent should have tried to steal
maybe Knight E5 or like FC he had to do
something he just took this pawn and now
why to move what do we do
we're not winning on spot I promise you
but we do have a pretty reasonable
Advantage so white to move what do we do
yep
good job and I'm attacking that poor
poor road because if the Rook moves then
great I'm attacking your life
so my opponents tried to do like in
between moves check reasonable a 95
might have been worth considered Awards
uh try as well uh he just played check I
moved and then he played Knight E5 so
why to move what do we do
probably have to move the queen
one of the options is Queen G3 but it's
is that the best one I would I would
encourage you to think and try to kind
of work to realign Maybe
foreign it is
so I think your two choices would be
between Queen G3 or queen F4
oops
yeah
quinita is also an option I forgot about
that
um but
which one would actually be more helpful
for you
true
uh possibly but not necessarily because
you are also attacking so you are
technically attacking upon a stroke on
f8 as well right
Knight takes D3 comes in the tempo
Bishop to F4 oh
what
well if you move the bishop that's your
opponent's gonna be a very lucky man
um queen of four if Knight takes I'm not
really worried about it because I can
just take it and I have a very strong
attack right away even taking would
probably work out
mm-hmm
so I'm not really worried about Knight
takes D3 with Queen F4 the problem with
Queen G3 is you are no longer attacking
this F7 Pawn so The Rook could just move
somewhere and if you take
yes also you don't have d4s anymore
yep so Queen F4 was the way to go uh my
opponent took his time here to play
Queen D4
so now question shall I eat this or do I
have something better
hey I've been known to be very tricky
with my questions so don't trust my
questions
try to actually think for yourself for
the position and see uh if what they
think is White's best move
I always say there's something better
because I don't need to give away my
strong Bishop fair but if you're winning
material that may be a good trade-off
I love how I'm confusing everybody
feels like little sparkles
I'm glad that you would love to skip
forward uh is it because you want the
answer or you just want to watch that
double speed
or the tension I see now
um to be fair I'm I've became really bad
with like speeding through my lectures
class lectures and everything I cannot
not watch people on double speed when I
watch Like school stuff so that that's
that's been becoming a problem to be
honest
I'm not so sure about F takes G6 because
H takes it back and that kind of like it
tells opponent I think
enough
said
I think FS is a very reasonable move F6
it's so your choices should be between
F6 or Bishop to xf8
their Rook is doing a really good job of
keeping the king under a cage so then
take away the Rook then point F6
sorry I just got the answer out of what
you were saying oh you want so you
wanted to play F6 but your reasoning is
that this Rook is like doing a good job
protecting the king well get rid of The
Rook first and then play F6 like a sense
where like it's keeping the king in a
cage oh but like if I have six they
could just move the Rook this is still
good for white yeah
yep and then push especially now that
this is coming up because if they take
well because if they take I can take
with queen and this is so painful I
don't even know how to win like which
way to choose to win this one
so opponent just played like H5 I don't
really know why I think they just wanted
to
check out the vibe I checked they ran I
checked they ran now white to move you
have a couple of great ideas to try to
win this but how do you think is the
most efficient efficient effective one
of the two uh which way is it which way
do you think is better to try to get
through this
foreign
you have a couple of ways to try to
continue and maximize your advantage
which one do you think is the most
effective or efficient way
is there a word that is like a mixture
of effective and efficient
probably if it's explicit
oh
yeah I if I ever have a kid the kid is
going doing spelling bee because I can't
I don't have enough words in my
vocabulary
oh optimal yeah thanks
yeah I agree like Rook B1 is also one of
the good ones I agree but I think like
your Pawn up here has done a wonderful
job kind of like messing around with
this King just open your poor other rook
and to top it off
pins yeah mm-hmm
so question what if the Kink takes
do you see any funny hymn tactics maybe
here well I was looking at Queen of six
Stars Queen F6 is totally fine not the
best one of the position right but so
when you're thinking I think your
thought process should be checks first
this was a check but if if you are still
doing checks you should think about like
the most forceful checks so double
checks
yep a check take a check check whatever
yeah I think we need to read title
you need to calculate it though it is a
good candidate move for calculated yeah
yeah correct what if the king takes it
though
okay king move somewhere
um maybe King D7 King C6 runs
possibly okay now you're getting
somewhere
yeah
yes so it is important to actually take
your time and calculate it thoroughly
but yes
uh Rook takes F7 would be the way to go
because if King takes you give this
check King moves check and Rook
Checkmate somewhere
yeah uh so yeah
uh so my opponent didn't take back he
just played Rook C8 and then what do we
do try to find the most comfortable way
to win don't try to be a hero
yep
exactly yeah and that was I think he
resigned somewhere around here
so yeah poor guy but like I don't think
I would have played this beautifully
this was a beautiful game if I didn't
play this move and the only reason I
played this move is because I prepared
against a specific opponent to be fair I
don't think I actually ever played this
at four line ever in my life after this
at least not in like real games maybe
I'll play direct training games but so
you don't need to play the opening that
you always play for every single game
you can choose to prepare against a
specific opponent you can choose to see
like if they have a specific weakness
that you can go the best example ever
that I have for that type of preparation
would be so I'm not showing that today
because I've shown that a couple times
over the years uh but feel free to feel
free to check on YouTube
um the game that I had against
who is actually playing in korean's cup
hey that game was oh my God a
masterpiece I prepared beautifully I had
beautiful tactics left and right I won
wonderfully
and if I'm being honest I was totally
hungover that game oh wait so do you
mean
the opponent who played
good night yes she's very strong yes
to be fair she was Stronger when we
played two but I still won
Dinara is also another super strong
chest boy
I also have a couple of fun games with
Dinara and John Saya
yeah
so this was Dragon
yeah this was a dragon opponent my
dragon this was a sicilian opening I
played the classical lines on my
opponents choose to kind of play the
dragon line which is G6 here there are
so many different ways that like white
can play is I played this F4 currently I
kind of go back and forth between Bishop
E3 or Bishop G5 or sorry maybe not that
Bishop G5 as much but like like Bishop
V2 Bishop V3 I go back and forth between
which side to Castle but this game I
prepared to play F4
do you want me to continue no
perfect
now speaking of another funny Dragon uh
this is the other game that I played oh
my God this game yeah could we change
the color of the board from that blue I
have no idea how to do that you might
have to ask Tracy about that no
yeah
I've learned my lesson not to mess with
Tracy she wants a chance she will change
it
otherwise she'll put my king in a diaper
I don't know if and I mean this
literally because we were doing simals
on Saturday and she changes my piece
configuration and
um she puts my king in a diaper there's
a clip of it somewhere like literally
there was a minute that I was playing
chess with my king in a diaper so
I learned not to mess with Tracy a long
time ago but she's outside I think we
can
to ask her
okay
I will let Tracy all right I brought it
up no it's fun I always want to talk
about how she put my king in a diaper so
okay
she's probably out there but okay so
this is another game that I played this
one I was not hungover
I played this game and World youth
Championship
uh same here actually 2014.
um I played this in South Africa Durban
man one of my biggest regrets is I went
all the way to South Africa middle of an
ebola outbreak but I didn't do anything
fun I just played chess hey it's Tracy I
was just talking about how you put my
king in a diaper and
and uh there was a question of the
announce where you can change the color
or whatnot but maybe ask Ben
and never ask it never mind
okay
go back put my king in a diaper again
um
oh my God okay
okay great
um
yeah well thank you night Captain uh how
long did I prepare before a game to be
able to get
okay that's a good point but again this
was a specific like this it was not a
game that I showed you but the I think
the game I had against gunai would have
been one of the best games I played in
my life so lesson learned
playing hungover no don't I was a
slightly hungover ah but this game I was
uh playing in South Africa and it was
go swing yeah worldview Championship
under 16 and I was playing decently and
I like I played well enough that the
last round if I win I win gold if I
don't win even if I draw I don't get
anything which was so sad so I had to
win
and I didn't but this specific game was
um right after the rest day and I was
playing a
um it was a girl from I want to say
Argentine from what I remember
her name is up here uh besso would be
the last time I believe and I was high
rated and I was playing fine and I had a
good game but I didn't want to play the
same dragon that I played earlier in the
year so I wanted to play something
different so I didn't want to do this
f4s I didn't want to do the what I
usually do I wanted to take the rest day
prepare I didn't necessarily learn a
whole new opening on the rest day but I
kind of like solidified what I was going
to play so I had like a chessboard and I
had my laptop and I was like playing it
out and I was having a great time and
um so I just went for not F4 that I
would usually play I played this
specific line and to be fair I was
playing this G-Force for a vlog for a
very very long time too
um so like G4 idea here so and also long
Castle so I was naturally playing this
bishop C4s but I I Was preparing two
Play Bishop C4s at some point in my life
but I hadn't really fully played it out
before this game so I prepared before
the game I go to the game I play this
bishop C4 I'm having a great time and I
know what I'm doing because I have
prepared it there are so many different
lines here the main line is the the like
the big line is the bishop D7 but there
are like takes that you need to know
they're like 97s there's so many things
but Bishop B7 is the main one
long Castle obviously Rook CH is a big
one Rook B8 is another one that you
might want to know like Knight E5 Queen
A5 there are so many many freaking lines
so you do need to take
um a lot of time to know what you're
doing so my point about Rook C8 I had it
prepared that I was going to play Bishop
V3 which is also the most polite move uh
at least in the master games and now
another big line here is Knight E5 or
take
or possibly even Knight A5 but the big
big lines are these Loops well that is
not a move are these two so my opponent
played Knight E5 I knew kind of what I
was doing but just to kind of test the
audience
um
knowledge in this opening uh their Rook
on C file is quite annoying there are it
is expected in Dragon especially in
these lines that there may be some weird
sacrifices with drifting C3 so if it's
white to move even if you don't know the
theory what do you think you're going to
do
I agree
so sorry it's a rule yeah like this is a
pretty scary thing and so is going to be
the h6c diet yeah also possibly so it is
a good idea to consider pushing this
Pawn you do want to do that but you
don't have enough
ammo I guess is that a thing you don't
have enough ammo you don't have enough
power to do this gift you want to like
play your kingish one first
yeah I thought ammo was the word but
somebody in the chat helped my English
um and so here like there are like three
like there are a couple of ideas these
are all ideas that black and tried
they're not as many and I need this is
another line this is another line so
there are a couple of Big Ideas that
black could try so it is very important
for white to be aware of how to handle
yourself
um if rookie eights I think now you can
start with
but if Knight C4 you have to deal with
it so you have to take and then what do
you do which Pawn would you push first
take your time take your time
so I'm gonna give it maybe a minute
because there is a difference between
which Pond you would decide to push so
take your time and
yeah
Firepower
well thank you Robert but this may be
the last time you actually see me before
I head out of town I am here until
Sunday so I do the classes like until
Sunday and Sunday but
ammo amno or ammo okay I at least know
how to write it
ammunition
so what are we thinking G or H H okay
it's G I'm sorry the problem with h is
they would put H back
so if you push H4 they play H5 back and
if you play G4
um they could take it or they could try
to get like funny with this and not yet
but they could take it maybe and if you
play H5 then they could take that or
even take with Knight so it gets a lot
more messy
yes but now they can take
it gets kind of messier than it needs to
be
so I think it's important to just play
G4 stop all their hopes and dreams with
H4
uh now it's five I don't think it works
as well because you can take if the
Knight takes you can just work on this
guy so like maybe Rook G1
possibly even like bring one of these
Knights to eat you to like do stuff here
but it is good to think about the
differences between which Pawn to push
um so G4 I thought I played B5 now do we
have time is it the right time to push
or should I do something here what do
you guys think
and Daniel is asking how to Advance
Medical School with chance is it tough
to squeeze online games between your
Coast load it is tough and that is why I
don't do it
um when I'm in medical school I'm in
medical school when I'm on break I'm on
break so I try to not mix and match so
that's kind of why I don't really play
as much
um I still do chess stuff like I still
have my students I still do a couple of
things for the club here and there
throughout the Academic Year and I am
still part of the mizutras team so if we
have something that requires my
undivided attention I'll kind of like
plan ahead so when I'm in a tournament I
try not to do like class work you know
because it's so hard like it's they're
like two completely different worlds and
if I try to come and keep going back and
forth I'm gonna fall somewhere so just a
question yeah what if you just take the
pawn on me that is a very fair question
let's say we take this Pawn
and they have Queen B8 what do you do
now
well if you move the night back now
you're going to you're kind of like
you're helping your opponents because
they gave up a pawn but they got the B
file they're attacking you your king may
need to move again somewhere
[Music]
uh King A1 this is kind of scaring me a
little
take because if you take they take
wait sorry wrong take
it
yeah much better not to deal with it
because like this B5 think about it this
way if your H Pawn wasn't here or your
g-pawn wasn't here would you be happier
would you have a better attack against
opponent King
Oh I thought you would say yes
uh if your Asian wasn't here or your GPA
wasn't here it feels like I would have a
better attacking as my opponent King so
by the same logic I don't want to eat
this Pawn because it would help my
opponent a little bit better attack
against me right
really not be happy the bonds workout s
fair fair but like
it would give you more uh availability
to attack you know if your age isn't if
you use your pawns and then they're gone
then sure Fair
uh one thing to keep in mind is B3 is
very possible Right There is Rook C5
that you need to know and this is like a
weird line that I really didn't want to
play but it is good for white so
yeah it's important to keep in mind that
if you are somebody who's playing this
line and I just play like and because I
played H4 it doesn't mean you have to
um
uh oh fun Dennis bars played this yeah
um oh my God like 13 years ago yep
Mizzou I used to be at SLU not at Mizzou
um so I want to play B4 and I think he
expected me to move the Knight this way
but the problem is if I go play chill
there's Queen A5 and if I push then
there's oh wait a little too much and
then this is just like opponent gets a
very decent counter attack so I don't
want to do that
so I just go I just wanted to play
Knight D5 to be fair I have had all of
these moves memorized and prepared
before the game for a couple extra moves
too so I wasn't sitting in the game and
thinking about it which psychologically
really really irritated my opponents
because like if I'm sitting if you're
sitting in a game on your punches of
splits it up let's say that and they're
playing all the good moves and you're
sitting there squeezing your head for
like half hour and then up on another
move it is not fun so it is that is also
another reason why I am super duper Pro
knowing your openings like as much as
you can because the more opening you
know especially if you know what your
product is playing you go through the
game it's like you would have the answer
to a quiz that your teacher is going to
give you like why wouldn't you do that
okay
um
so I do like the idea of Knight D5 I
liked it beforehand too because I
prepared it and my opponent took I took
back and then she played Queen in it
um I think Queen A5 may have been the
more like expected possible I don't want
to say better but like I think it's more
expected to do that but the queen A8 is
still Mainline
and because I still had it prepared haha
I played H5 she took I still had it
prepared Knight F5 still preparation
take take King moves I took and rookie
Gates I'm like well okay I'm out of my
preparation this is like move 22 I'm
about to make and I finally have to use
my brain so they're attacking my knight
um this move should be easy right I have
to move the Knight correct and then my
opponent put A5 and I'm like oh my God
okay what do I do now
I don't have it prepared I don't know
what to do I'm like okay take a deep
breath oh I have I had a good chunk of
time at least an hour
yeah so it is white to move and your
opponent just played A5 you don't know
the theory anymore I mean it's freaking
End Game you should know the theory but
so what do you think white should do
here take your time take your time
and the biggest lesson that I'm hoping
you'll learn after this move is just
don't trust your opponents opponents can
make mistakes all the time so why to
move what do you think whites should do
take your time take your time
well think it's true
thank you
oh wait after H6 Bishop E5 is an f48
trap yep oh well
and then like those six or Bishop D4
first oh
so literally like this game all the only
single move that I had to find
was H6
which I did fine I'm proud of myself for
that but like everything else I knew
exactly from before the game so again if
you know you're gonna go to an exam and
your teacher is going to give you this
like 10 sample questions that tells you
to look it over you look it over because
if it happens it's good to be prepared
so I was prepared my appointment should
be five F4 bye bye Bishop
and then also bye bye Rook and buy buy
more stuff and I she just resigned here
so that was quite fun
yeah I have another dragon that I want
to show you
what did I sack
I don't sacrifice anything I just ate
yeah
um but like here to be fair she is not I
mean she's a little bit worse she's not
losing she had to play Bishop C6 which
would I play B3 she would take I would
take this and then
I have this
whoops
um I mean your Bishop is also pinned
also you may lose all of these
okay
why does it still a little bit better
but like Bishop C6 was a move she had to
play or maybe take or maybe bishop E6
she had to like deal with this Knight
and she didn't
cool
yep she trapped her on Bishop okay we
got a couple minutes I may not get
through all of this game but this is
also another game that I really liked
when was the school thing this was yeah
a year before that
so another dragon and if you recall I
was just talking about how I played this
how I used to play this early G4 and
dragon I still play it sometimes because
people don't know how to play it so it's
kind of fun
um oh there's a question one episode if
Bishop f8 happened in that game I had
Bishop D4 because it was a check
so there are a couple of whoops there
are a couple of pretty good moves here
Bishop E6 is a one of them H5 is a
pretty annoying one taking is good
um but my opponents played take sorry
sneeze is coming
I apologize for audience ears
I sneezed with my whole body I'm
literally every time I sneeze I feel
like I give myself a slight concussion
um
so my opponent took to be fair if you
look at the name the dude is well at the
time he was Tiny I think he was he's
younger than me I don't know how much
um but he is
um he was like a hundred something
points more than me at the time like 10
years ago oh my God 10 years ago when we
played but now he's like 26 something so
I wish I beat you when I was 2600 but
still
um
so he played this line because I think
he just wanted to play more aggressively
and I took he took and I knew my lines
to a certain points I didn't know
exactly what I was doing I knew I have
to play this might be true to stop all
this stuff from happening
um so I just kind of wanted to
um
I kind of wanted to see like how I could
continue right
so I think possibly like Bishop G1 may
have been the better choice at the time
my theory might have let me Theory
definitely change unless I don't know 10
years whoops about a night B3 I did stop
some of these ideas so she played uh he
sorry played D5 which was a little
questionable maybe take first and then
try for D5 ideas but
he played d flat first I took and then
he took over here which started to kind
of relieve a lot of pressure for me
possibly taking here would have been a
little bit more comfortable anyways took
took and she uh he played Queen takes D5
it is attacking my rook and I think I
should have taken with a B Pawn but I
took with the queen because I didn't
want to mess my Pawn structures and I
was slightly hopeful to be able to do
long Castle
um my preparation has ended at this
point but the move G4 that I played was
strong enough that is kind of carrying
me through for a little bit I need to
defend this bishop and then I think
Knight B4 was kind of a stretch for him
he should have possibly taken this and
if I take with Rook then he can check
and if I go here then maybe he can try
to stop me from long castleing and then
he could try like the further attacks
because he does have two pawns for a
bishop but his big uh Advantage is that
my king is in the middle of the board so
as long as my king stays in the middle
of the board he does have a decent
counter attack he's 22 yeah thank you
um so he played night before and I just
played Bishop D3 which was very
reasonable I'm stopping your attack so
I'm attacking you back haha and if you
play something
oh yeah also if he gives check or
whatnot I also have Rook G1 so I'm not
worried about this if he takes it now
this yep that happens too so I play
Bishop D3 she took I take and I'm like
please can we trade queens and we do it
I'm like yes my king is safe
and now this light also feels kind of
trapped right like I don't know why he
did this I think
so psychologically like when you are
attack attack attack
it's harder for you to stop attacking
right but it's like you keep attack
attack attack and then your Queens are
traded up and your attack kind of dies
down and you're like
okay what now right so I think that's
what happened to him because if he just
placed chill I'm like I have a bishop
for two pawns so this is a very
comfortable position for me I don't need
to risk anything all I need to do is
maybe kick this guy away maybe develop
this dude to get the night somewhere
better I don't need to play risky
um so I think he just kind of messed up
and he just gave me the other one which
was really happy I was thrilled he tried
to kind of like jump up a more chunk of
Pawns
but like now all I have to do is just
not mess up just don't blunder play
comfortably and make sure these bad boys
don't start the race
right and all I had to do was again just
play comfortable
uh also yes you writes uh a c blue
yeah black was more overconfidence but I
mean the bishop G4 line isn't
necessarily a terrible line but you need
to know exactly what you're doing and I
don't think you know
um but yeah this was kind of a fun game
because it gave me the um like I mean
you can push the pawns but I'm gonna eat
them one by one thank you oh my they're
rookie
sorry yeah this was a sneaky one right
yep I mean taking I don't think I'm
losing you anything but like why would I
yes no no reason to risk it so when you
have this much material advantage you do
not need to risk it
yep
um so Daniel is asking how do I remember
all these games man I saved my games I
saved my I've been saving my games for
years so I just kind of go back and I um
just pulled him I don't remember all
these I remember like the opening and I
remember the opponents but I don't
remember like how the game actually wins
for a while but yeah so we just kind of
Shuffle pieces for a bit I have two
pieces for two pawns all I have to do is
not freaking blunder and I'm getting
there and this kind of feels a little
checkmated so he resigned here but it
was a very nice game and it says that
like I wanted to show you a couple of
dragons and kind of show you the three
different lines that I played
um to be totally honest I think I have
shown these games before
so if you think you have seen them
before you are not crazy I probably have
shown them before but not in the sense
of how I prepared them so it is really
important to try to prepare not just for
the game but against your opponents so I
think that's kind of the
the whole theme of tonight right prepare
like a pro so yeah
any questions
or actually in medical school we were
told not to ask any questions because it
means like people who are more likely to
say no so I have it's better to ask what
questions do you have for me so
right now you're thinking well maybe I
should ask questions
all right well if no questions it was a
pleasure oh I have a question yeah
powerful
uh depends I mean in in the early game
the most powerful squares I would think
would be the center so I just want to
kind of grab those but if you're
thinking like more attack wise then the
f2f7 scores would be the most
uh the like not again maybe not the
powerful but the most influential ones
because those would be the ones that I
want to go attack so
okay
um or do we have this every Thursday yep
we do but it is for the GM Marine
residence and I'm not doing that anymore
after Sunday I'm going to be going home
so somebody else actually uh Robert
hunius who hungaski will be doing it so
tune in for him for next week but we
also do have Karen's cup so don't forget
about that actually how can you may or
may not broadcast
here so because of recurrence cup our
broadcast schedule may or may not be
changed so just tune in for that but
just watch the Korean stuff watch your
sir your life will be sweet with the
other Nazi Alright good night everybody
[Music]